this is the Victorian Albert Museum like
you've never seen it before
the first of its kind the young VNA is
not about children but for children and
run by them too well some of them this
is a museum for doing for playing for
imagining for Designing for hanging out
with your friends what I really love
about young DNA is that it really turns
its on its head the idea museum is
somewhere that you'll go and be really
quiet and you'll learn somehow through
just looking at the displays this is
saying no come and be loud it's a space
for you hurry up taxi driver I've got
somewhere to be I'm going for going it's
Mission simple pushing creativity in
education and showing learning and
having fun can go hand in hand when I
was younger I was quite curious I quite
liked touching things and stuff and like
I felt quite restricted in those museums
which is what made it so boring it's
clear that inclusivity is at the heart
of the young VNA this space and
everything in it was tested design
created by 22 000 Young people across
seven years one example is this Arts and
Science exhibition designed by children
with prosthetic limbs they didn't want
to hide their difference they didn't
want a prosthetic that was pretending to
look like a real armor or a leg or a
real limb and actually they felt that
they had a superpower because of this
difference no one's a bit celebrated in
some way so they actually drawn the
language of superheroes and that
superpower and children can customize
their prosthetic depending on on their
mood or what they feel like doing that
day so it really gives them kind of a
power to change it whenever they want
here reimagining spaces and pushing the
limits to creativity is encouraged for
all children access to cultural learning
is becoming Preserve of a few that can
afford to do that and for schools to
afford to do that people and families
also are making very difficult choices
about what they spend their money on
making this Museum free we hope we're
putting down some of the barriers to
accessing this and making sure that even
when times are tough in our society but
there are places you can come a message
given the Royal seal of approval earlier
this week they tell me stories all the
times anyone else have a story
with carts inflation and the cost of
living Illuminating the minds of
Britain's young couldn't have come at a
better time Saba Chowdhury Sky News East
London